mesdames messieurs bonsoir le seul
inculpé dans la sphère de l'assassinât
du petit grégory restera donc en prison
les avocats de bernard laroche avait
pourtant demandé à plusieurs reprises la
mise en liberté provisoire de leur
client
il a évoqué la maigreur du dossier
d'instruction les juges de nancy en ont
décidé autrement après huit jours de
réflexion ils ont toutefois reconnu que
la culpabilité de bernard laroche
n'était pas pour autant démontrer nous
retrouvons tout de suite sur place
isabelle des schleck qui a suivi cette
journée c'est un refus la phrase de m
weiler enlève tout espoir à sa femme
marie ange et à sa famille bernard
laroche restera en prison
les magistrats de la chambre
d'accusation estimé qu'il existait
suffisamment de présomptions contre
l'inculpé pour justifier son maintien en
détention
uriel sa belle soeur de 15 ans avait en
effet affirmé dans un premier temps
l'avoir accompagné sur les lieux du
crime à la prison l'avocat a trouvé son
client révolter et protestons toujours
de son innocence
avec l'autorisation du bâtonnier de
l'ordre des avocats d'epinal je peux
vous dire que un rejet de demande de
mise en liberté ne signifie pas qu une
culpabilité est démontrée
et d'ailleurs la chambre d'accusation
dans son arrêt a bien précisé qu'à ce
stade de la procédure la culpabilité de
la roche n'était pas démontrée outre les
présomptions de culpabilité la cour
d'appel a estimé que les investigations
en cours dans l'omc est exigent est
également que bernard laroche restent
incarcérés